j'ai la vigne à dsk comme 75% des femmes
et je vous demandait de réagir nous sur
twitter également tous ceux qui nous
regardent ce soit les femmes ce sont les
hommes soit n'importe qui est ce que
comme 75% des femmes vous trouvez qu'un
homme qui cuisine est très sexy oui je
suis assez d'accord c'est vrai oui mais
un homme qui bricolent aussi en fait
mouche avec moi je sais pas exactement
[Rires]
je bricole où fleurit connais vous aimez
bricoler d'aller vers des trucs que vous
avez je bricole offre est jeté des
briques à nations trucks essien hommes
qui cuisinent médiation il ya des femmes
moi j'ai franchement j'ai connu des
meufs à elle et non elle pouvait pas
voir un mec qui cuisinent quoi pourquoi
ouais on vraiment elle trouve que l ai
trouvé que c'était pas du tout sexy mais
ça non mais je ne vais pas si moi je
pense que c'est sexy parce que justement
c'est c'est prometteur on image soit on
imagine que si il est gourmand de
nourriture de la ville paul est même
n'aurait pas aimé cuisiner
bien sûr il va c'est vrai d'ailleurs
exactement vrai qu'elle n'a pas du tout
sexy j'en étais sûr pas du tout mais par
contre que je trouve sexy c'est un homme
qui a le sens de l'orientation
[Rires]
dakar avec tomtom ça me dirait l'homme
qui a le sens de l'orientation ou parce
qu'au match n'est pas du tout et je
trouve ça sexy un mec oui moi je suis la
station il ya aucune meuf qui m'a dit un
jour à très sexy j'ai fais quoi tout a
garé sa voiture
le mec allait rentrer chez eux le soir
alors avec 2 ou fin
qu'est-ce qui fait et c'est un truc de
ouf c'est quoi on s'est garés ici et ben
on est sorti du théâtre savait où était
sa voiture je te jure à sens de
l'orientation
la mine est d'accord avec moi mais
entièrement risée non mais parce que il
a généralement les mecs entre choi les
oublie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la même scène avec elle elle avec le ils
sont dus à des clés qui vous est oui
alors alors moi je trouve ça mais alors
mais pas du tout du tout du tout sexy
ainsi les négliger j'aime quand il a les
bras dans le cambouis qu'avec jean
l'herm bras musclés et tout à la cuisine
pas nous touche tous qu'étant cap et
rewmi j'aime autant que ce soit lumière
et en plus le dernier à caqueter sortie
cravacher millas incluse les mecs ses
cuisines vie d'avant vous déformez plan
de travail dégueulasse il faut passer
d'accord pour ne pas qu'il est bon mais
c'est moi ou les missiles et fait sens
[Applaudissements]
et puis à la région elle veut pas parler
ce qu'elle ne connaît pas sa cuisine non
je connais pas moi je trouve ça très
excitant non merci on coupe un gigot
autant si la cuillère en bois la poêle
qui fait se tramer moi franchement moi
je vais faut pas extraordinaire alors
les promesses de commandes 9 mois je
vide apparent le choc castaldi il
cuisine n'ont pas pas des masses mais
j'aime bien faire l'amour dans ma
cuisine en famille parce qu'il ya plein
de choses à inventer demain et non c'est
très pratique mais il est fou ce qu'on
peut prendre de la chantilly par exemple
il ya plein de choses il ya deux bombes
à ses bons à cinq mètres carrés parce
que moi j'ai la tête dans le frigo le
cul dans les clips
[Applaudissements]
c'est le magnifique
sachez que pour 75 % des femmes en tout
cas vous trouvez qu'un homme qui cuisine
c'est très sexy on va on va regarder
oui 67% tenons à 33% par mois j'ai
changé d'avis je vais prendre des cours
de cuisine dans moi je sais je sais rien
et tout près de moi une femme qui
cuisine ça vous plaît alors s'il vous
plaît arrêtez avec vos obsessions de moi
et mes sincères et c'est tout le monde
cyrine mais intéresse personne et bien
sûr personne avec un gars été pensé
comme un sujet vous êtes manager mais où
est bien sûr une femme qui cuisine c'est
magnifique
vous savez moi j'aime et je respecte la
femme dans toutes les situations